the breast cancer deaths have declined
however it is still the second most
common cancer among women in the U.S but
it is the leading cause of cancer deaths
among Hispanic women Denise Valdez tells
us more about the increased cases in our
buddy check reports
Dr R Salon Solomon is with Optum care
Breast Care the latest CDC numbers show
Hispanic women are diagnosed in slightly
higher numbers The Five-Year breast
cancer survival rate for Latino women
tends to be lowered and Caucasian women
by about four percent so we're looking
at 92 percent versus 88 percent plus
it's more likely to be discovered at a
later stage Hispanic women have higher
odds than non-hispanic white women to be
diagnosed with tumors that are larger
and hormone receptor negative making it
tougher to treat once your tumor becomes
larger or your lymph node becomes
positive then you're hot you're more
likely to have a later stage cancer
invasive breast cancer is the most
commonly diagnosed cancer and the
leading cause of cancer death among
Hispanic women so awareness is key Dr
Solomon says one way to overcome it is
to have conversations at home so so I
think that's the first place that it can
start where we raise awareness within
our own families you know to get your
mom or your sister or your grandma to go
get their mammogram that's what we try
to do here every month we encourage you
to do your breast self exam either in
the shower or laying down because nobody
knows their body better than you and
don't put off that annual screening
either like all cancers it's best to
catch it early for Buddy check Denise
Valdez